[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
aimchs u.s rapid knockouts it's the
third game between magnus carlsen and
young shoot of dudum as we've seen at
the first game ended by magnus winning
and the second game ended in a draw now
this third game it features a really
awesome move and the entire game is
pretty cool so let's check it out and
then we're gonna enjoy something else uh
so uh magnus with the white pieces opens
with e4 now duda goes for the sicilian
defense we have c5 knight f3 e6 and now
b3 by magnus the listerine in attack uh
we have knights the c6 and the bishop to
b2 so the early fianchetto of the dark
square bishop
we have a6 by black and now striking in
the center with d4 that we have captures
captures and now queen to a5 check uh we
have knights to d2 magnus blocks the
check and now knight to f6 uh we have uh
knight captures and c6 the d4 pawn is
attacked uh
so uh
as the knight on d2 is pinned but magnus
first captures on c6 with d captures and
now bishop to d3 he simply defends his
pawn uh and now bishop to b4 preventing
white from castling uh if the king
castles you're going to lose your knight
you can't play c3 the c3 square is
defended twice uh attacked twice in this
case but there is uh something you can
do
so this position has been reached before
and no moves are a3 just asking black do
you want to trade or do you want to move
back the bishop and also just c4
those are the known moves but the moves
the move magnus plays is the move from
the thumbnail uh and uh here magnus
played king to e2 and if you think about
it it's it's very
simple and straightforward i mean uh
we want to move the knight we want to
get the rook into the game and then
later on we're going to play some like
f3 f4 plays the king on f2 uh and it
doesn't seem like black has any way of
taking advantage of this so how can we
and if for example
sorry if queen to h5 check then we
simply block with knight to f3 so king
to e2 uh
never played before but it is as of move
10 that we have a completely new game so
let's see how do that deals with this
novelty so obviously you could go for an
end game with characters characters
characters and captures but you're
already down in the match and you're
going uh into an end game against magnus
where he has the bishop fair maybe not
the you know the best course of action
so instead duda just castles he says all
right magnus will still need some time
to get his king to safety we have
knights to see for now attacking duda's
queen and queen back to c7 uh we've
bishop to e5 for the harassing dudas
queen queen back to d8 and then now c3
now the bishop will move and now we have
our e1 square for the rook if needed uh
we have bishop back to e7 and now bishop
back to c2 again magnus offers a queen
trade uh yes now duda will also have a
bishop pair but this light square bishop
is just uh an ugly one for example if
captures captures it's going to take you
uh well
a lot of time to get this light square
bishop into the game and like i said
you're already down in the match
uh so after bishop the c2 just knights
the d7 by duda and now comes bishop to
d6 now magnus says all right i'm going
to continue in a principled matter uh
yeah i'm going to trade off your active
bishop and then you're going to be left
with this uh well pretty much useless
bishop so duda starts with b5 uh chases
away this knight and he wants to further
advance the pawns on the queen side a5
b4 and then clear this diagonal for his
light square bishop so that's his plan
we have knight back to e3 by magnus and
now comes a5 you could continue with
something like knight to f6 bring the
queen to a5 go after maybe the c3 pawn
uh but duda's plan also has merit with
a5
and now magnus uh plays e5 so now the
bishop is very nicely placed here now
your black captures you can even capture
with the pawn here and have a nice pass
pawn on on d6 but more importantly
you've cleared this diagonal for your
light square bishop so here we have b4
uh now black might at some point play
bishop to a6 but it's still not clear
because if white plays c4 then the
bishop and this diagonal will also be
well useless
and uh
not something we want to do but still if
c4c5 then we cleared this diagonal for
the bishop so duda has some some ideas
of how to get this bishop into the game
but magnus starts with queen to d3 just
uh you know threatens checkmate so you
have to deal with that we have g6 and
now comes rook 8 d1 putting a lot of
pressure on this on this d file
we have bishop captures on d6 and now
you could capture with the pawn or the
queen but magnus decides that this pawn
is better suited to remain on e5 and he
captures with the queen so queen
captures on d6 uh and now again whenever
you play bishop to a6 check we're just
going to block with c4 but if you try b
captures on c3 kind of saying okay now
i'm playing bishop to a6 then magnus
will play f4 and then bishop to a6 check
ends up with king to f2 and magnus's
king is still very safe on f2 he's going
to get the other rook into the game and
his position is is just fine so after
queen captures and b6 do that price
queen to g5 now putting pressure on the
e5 pawn and magnus now just captures on
c6 uh so first we have to defend the
knight because rook captures bishop
captures queen capture just wins two
pieces for the rook so rook to a7 also
the rook was attacked on a8 and finally
now c4 by magnus and now after all is
said and done okay dude wins back his
pawn so queen captures on e5 uh the
material is equal but uh magnus has uh
has a past c pawn and it could be very
unpleasant if you're thinking about
capturing with the knight it doesn't
really work queen to c5 now it attacks
the rook the knight can't move because
the queen hangs it's a tricky position
for black
so after this c4 move we have queen
captures an e5 by duda and now magnus
again just offers a queen trade he says
okay let's trade queens i have passed c
pawn uh life is good uh dude of course
not interested in this he plays queen to
h5 check with f3 and now comes f5 by
duda and this is the critical moment in
the game where he just gives up the e6
pawn for magnus to capture so he can
activate his pieces and somehow go after
carlson's king that's still in the
center of the board uh if duda was not
down in the match he would probably play
some like queen to c5 then magnus would
maybe trade queens maybe not maybe he
would just continue pushing
and say okay if you want to trade we're
gonna trade
but i'm gonna recapture on these six and
this is probably what we would see but
uh duda is down in the match so we have
f5 and not magnus happily captures on e6
with check king g7 we have queen back to
d6 uh and now what do you play here he's
a his uh threat is queen to d4 check
which would win the rook on a7 so here
knight to f6 by duda now this doesn't
really do anything as the knight blocks
check so still queen to d4 attacking the
rook and now rook to e7 now duda wants
to double up here and perhaps he can do
some damage along the e file with king
to f2 magnus on pins rook f the e8 and
now rook h to e1 bringing the last rook
into the game and now carlson's pieces
are fully mobilized and well it's it's a
question what what can do the play here
is the is the h2 pawn free for grabs
well not really if you capture on h2
then knight the d5 is super annoying as
it comes with a double attack here uh
also the rook is attacked twice so what
what can you do here uh not much if you
capture you can't capture with the
knight the knight is pinned uh but other
than that you really don't have um
don't have a good move uh so of course
instead of capturing duda finally
develops this bishop it took him some 30
moves but the light square bishop also
joins the party uh and now magnus plays
queen to f4
uh freeing up the d6 square or rather
the d file for this rook to d6 move
which could come in handy uh putting
pressure on the knight you will be able
to attack the bishop here maybe go after
those spawns and still it doesn't seem
like black has all that much to do here
so here king to g8 duda gets the king
away from the dark square diagonal and
not knight to f1 uh magnus is just up up
upon and he wants to he wants to trade
rooks uh so what do you play here duda
starts with g5 uh he has to try
something otherwise uh he he can just
resign we have queen captures on f5 and
now only now rook captures an e1 rook
captures and queen to a for check now of
course the king cannot move so knight to
g3 and now queen to d4 with check we
have king to f1 and if you notice the
the white king made uh made a nice
square here he started from e1 then king
e2 king f2 king to f1 this is how uh
2800's play good chess
and here do the trades rook capture
sunny one king captures and now queen to
e3 check but now knight to e2 guarding
both c1 and g1 so duda uh can continue
harassing the white king so duda played
king the g7 uh but now magnus just
played queen captures on a5 and it was
in this position on move 38 that young
sister of duda resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
you're threatening a queen to c7 check
which wins the bishop if you try to move
the queen to defend the bishop then you
lose the g5 pawn uh if you well there's
really nothing to be done here even if
you manage to defend everything you're
gonna lose the b four pawn then you have
three connected past pawns to worry
about on the queen side and there's just
nothing for for black to even try so of
course here he resigned and uh
the fourth game did not happen as magnus
won two and the second game ended in a
draw so magnus wins the first match and
uh
maybe you've noticed maybe you didn't
but we didn't have a positive video
moment in this game as it was pretty
much uh you know nothing to be solved
here after duda gave up his e6 pawn it
was pretty pretty clear what magnus had
to do but there is a beautiful position
from the game ahmedyarovarunyan uh and
that is this position mamidarov has the
white pieces and the arunan has the
black pieces and this is the the current
situation uh arunyan captured on a4 he
captured a pawn here with the rook but
now he's completely lost mamadou has a
really really fine attack but you have
to you know choose your moves correctly
so feel free to pause the video and
figure out how to win this uh for
mamadyarov while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
devious plan and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's queen
to h2 tripling here on this h file and
now your plan is uh queen to h5 to g6
and it you have to realize how beautiful
this is because now uh okay okay black
could stop this with queen to f7 we're
gonna discuss this but let's say just
rook captures on c3 just so so you check
out the plan queen to h5 uh now we play
rook to a8 we bring a rook to help out
with the defense of the back rank now
comes to rook the g6 and now the black
queen doesn't really have a good square
if you go here we simply win the queen
with this move and if you go to e7 we
still play rook to g8 to check we don't
care and after captures and captures
king will capture notice that the d5
pawn is
guarding the e6 square so now we simply
deliver checkmate queen h8 to check king
f7 rook h7 check king g6 queen to j to
check queen has to block and now queen
captures it will be checkmate so this is
one way to do it another way is
well a bit of a sturdier defense for
black uh if black after queen to h2
defends with the queen to f7 not guards
the h5 square we still play it we don't
care and now after queen captures we're
going to capture with our rook here and
now how do you play this the f6 pawn is
hanging
but also we're just threatening rook to
g6 to g8 so you don't even have time to
worry about your pawn so you have to
defend against this back rank idea so
now we capture on f6 and now everything
is going to fall and the white simply
has a winning winning position for
example rook captures on c3 uh we can
even play bishop captures on g5 and now
if let's say king to g7
now we're just going to move the rook
and play bishop to f6 and that's game so
if black prevents this let's say king to
g7 now we capture on v6 and again bishop
to f6 is coming h8 is coming and that's
it so this was the position but mahmoud
yarov did not finish this precisely
arunian defended and in the end it was
arunian who won this game so
congratulations to everyone who found it
as you've uh defeated a very very strong
player
uh so yeah that's the game or the games
i hope you guys enjoyed them i would
like to thank seth hanson jessica
ricovicious haydn quincy aditya para
parasarati and christopher alexandra
sopa for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day